it was a challenge to his presidency
before he even became president and one
year on from the riot at Capitol Hill
Joe Biden marked the anniversary with a
speech to the nation
for the first time in our history
a president
had not just lost an election
he tried to prevent the peaceful
transfer of power
as a violent mob breached the capital
but they failed
the crowd marched on the heart of
democracy in the U.S to challenge the
certification of the 2020 presidential
election Donald Trump claimed he'd been
cheated
and we're going to the Capitol and
fueled by anger and lies his supporters
fought battles across Capitol Hill as
they tried to stop Congress doing its
job this wasn't a group of tourists
this was an armed Insurrection but this
moment this challenge to American
democracy has not brought the country
together instead President Biden's
speech just shows the fracture in U.S
politics we must decide
what kind of nation are we going to be
are you going to be a nation that lives
Not By the Light of the truth
but in the shadow of Lies
many Republicans opted not to attend the
event some claiming Democrats were
politicizing the attack others because
they were afraid of offending Donald
Trump the former president himself was
due to hold a news conference in Florida
on the anniversary he canceled he was
told it would look bad he did Issue a
statement saying Joe Biden was using him
to deflect from the awful job he was
doing as president and was seeking to
divide the country
Trump continues to claim without
evidence that the election was stolen
that he won the election and American
democracy still has to come to terms
with him his supporters
and the day they stormed the capital
Alan Fisher Al Jazeera the White House
so here's what we'll do this hour inside
and outside Capitol Hill with John
hendren and Mike Hannah let's go inside
first Mike Hannah who listened to that
speech along with us a little bit
earlier I recall one of the many books
written about President Trump was called
fire and fury it was a bit of that from
Joe Biden today
it was indeed we have seldom seen
President Biden so angry in terms of an
address to the nation uh singling out
former president Trump as the real cause
of what he described as a Web of Lies he
didn't even dignify the former president
by using his name he just referred
repeatedly to the former president
accuse him of putting a power above
principles and accusing him of spreading
lies for profit and for power so very
strong words from President Biden but he
was also careful to point out that the
lie that the election was flawed in some
way has been discounted by every single
Court in the country that it's come
before President Biden making particular
reference to a series of Court judgments
ranging from federal courts to the
Supreme Court itself which has upheld
that any Claim about election fraud is a
lie now President Biden and stressing
that throughout his address to the
nation and yet despite this fact there
is still the majority of Republicans it
appears who continue to support former
president Trump in his false claim and
who also continue to support him in
attempting to whitewash exactly what
happened on this day a year ago
thank you Mike Hanna inside the Capitol
building and now outside with John
hendron
voters protect democracy so there were
pro-democracy Gatherings today tell us
what it was like and show us around
that's right I'm right in front of what
is to be a pro-democracy rally supported
by dozens of organizations and there
will be uh Democrats here speaking
liberal and Progressive Democrats no
Republicans all out here and this is
really a call for voting rights to
support voting rights which is something
Chuck Schumer the the leader in the
Senate for the Democrats is trying to do
right now he's trying to seize this
January 6th event and use it to propel
voting rights as one state after another
actually restricts more voting rights so
it's right here that you'll be seeing in
a matter of hours a group of people
gathering together I can tell you it's a
whole lot more peaceful here on them all
than it was a year ago at this time
today but later on we're going to start
seeing other protesters people who don't
agree with the folks right here and
that's at the D.C jail a group called
look ahead America and that's only one
of 15 across the country
from Hawaii to Florida and the reason
they're at jails is that that's where
the January 16 rioters many of them
still are right now many of them have
been arrested about 700 plus out of the
estimated 2500 people who participated
in breaching the capital back there and
that might get a little more Saucy but
that doesn't happen until a little after
Dawn several hours from now but so far
it's been very peaceful as a matter of
fact more peaceful than I would say on a
regular day but we may see that change
over the course of the afternoon after
these fiery speeches right okay spend
more with John hendren later on in the
day as we see what happens with those
protests thank you John
always pleased to welcome Ian Bremer to
Al Jazeera president of the Eurasia
group bang Sarah media he's on Skype
from New York high e and uh Journey so
much to talk about
um I want to talk about Joe Biden's
speech first of all what did you make of
his decision to well attacked Donald
Trump if not mention him by name and
whether that actually just plays into
Donald Trump's game of of words of of
Wars of words I should say
look I mean I agree with a lot of what
President Biden had to say but of course
the backdrop is that over the course of
the last year
we've done nothing to address the
underlying political divisions there's
so much sharper in the United States
than in any other Advanced industrial
democracy around the world today uh the
election in 2020 was badly broken by the
sitting president
um and he's doing everything he can to
ensure that 2024 will be as bad if not
worse and so when Biden at the beginning
of the year said America's back it's
hard to comport America is back with the
speech we heard today that democracy is
in crisis and we have to address it
these are really big domestic challenges
and the country is very deeply divided
they are and not to be well I am going
to be pessimistic here how on Earth can
anyone Joe Biden or other always fix
those sorts of divisions or try to
bridge them when you have got a large
majority of people who think that
storming the capital A year ago was okay
that it was the right thing to do in
fact
well look the political divisions in the
United States have not emerged over one
or two years they've been growing for
decades and so addressing them will be a
matter of a generation not just one
president I do think that putting over a
trillion dollars into infrastructure uh
will matter I I think that if they can
move on their build back better plan
even a small piece of it that
redistribution uh is is necessary and I
also think that demographic changes in
the United States that will make the
United States a minority white country
by 2045 will also change the political
realities of the country and political
parties will need to adapt to that but
none of those things are going to help
us for 2024 and that's the problem
because the midterm elections coming up
this year in November the Republicans
are going to win the house they may win
the Senate and they're probably going to
win a lot of Key State legislatures and
gubernatorial races that are critical
for sort of defying the 2024 election
and Trump who continues to persist in
advancing the lie that the election was
stolen rigged against him is running the
Republican party and the near-term
challenge that's your pessimism that's
not getting addressed even by Biden's
speech today let's talk about something
else in the interim and that is the
actual January 6th investigation the
committee a lot of Point made that it is
led by a prominent Republican uh Liz
Cheney but again what do you actually
expect that to
well what will it achieve as far as
accountability goes
oh nothing and nothing else it's not led
by a prominent Republican it's led by a
formerly prominent Republican who was
removed from her leadership position
because she persisted in publicly
attacking former president Trump against
the will of the majority of the party
and the base that's the problem I mean
the people that actually went against
Trump on the election uh results are a
lot of them are getting primaried
several of them are saying that they're
resigning and not going to even seek
re-election as I said this is this is
unfortunately I mean January 6th the
lessons that have been learned have only
been learned by one side of the
political aisle there are I mean a
majority of people that support Trump
believe that the people that occupied
the Capitol building a year ago were
patriots that were there to ensure that
the election would not be stolen and and
they believe that their principal
adversaries are not external agents
their the political opponents inside
their own country democracies healthy
democracies do not persist for long when
you have that kind of reality
you've talked about and rightly a lot of
big picture issues democracy as a whole
I wonder how much the American people
are listening to it they've got so much
on their plate at the moment already
you know just covered on its own is more
than enough to deal with we have a day
like this where it becomes prominent
again sometimes the January 6 committee
will make some headlines and it'll be on
the news but I wonder if this if they
realize how big and important this is
uh I look I I think they recognize that
it's important but they see it as
important for fundamentally different
reasons you have to recognize that the
United States today is the most powerful
country in the world and that power is
not going away it's percentage of global
GDP is the same now as it was 20 years
ago a period of time when the Europeans
went down the Japanese went down all
this new technology markets hitting
record levels and yet U.S economic
inequality is higher than the rest of
the G7 and identity politics you have a
whole bunch of undereducated white men
who feel rightly they're losing a lot of
status you put those two things together
in the information Echo chamber that's
magnified by social media and then you
weaponize it with someone like Donald
Trump a narcissist completely unfit for
office who's only interested in
promoting his own personal agenda you
get January 6. I mean it would be
surprising if that wasn't going on in
the United States MO most Americans
believe it's going to happen again I
agree with that my God
we love talking to you
um thank you so much for your time do
appreciate it
good to see you guys Happy New Year you
too